years ago Alex said to me when I
proposed to you it will be the best
proposal ever Back to the Future became
a part of our relationship together
probably when you showed me like your
onesie footie pajamas we listened the
help of our very dear friend and
fantastic photographer Rikki middles
worth all we had to do was stand there
Ricky had to make it what it is and I
just on a wild hare decided to post the
picture to Reddit Halloween is her
favorite movie of all time I get some of
her friends to scoop her up and tell her
that they're gonna go on a walking tour
of the locations and then as she's
rounding an iconic corner Michael Myers
will pop out okay so here's me waiting
for Kat to come you must have been so
nervous I was so nervous and I didn't
realize that the mask was gonna make it
really hard for me to hear they start
chanting which they're doing right now
founder can't hear is now well yell a
little louder
yay Haddonfield in the night ha ha ha
that's real and from heat my memory of
this I blacked out in this really I
don't remember getting down on the knee
I remember once I was down it was
important to me okay honey stop talking
oh look at that face yeah yeah
were you serious yeah
you can't predict what it's actually
gonna be like in that moment you know
but it's really special it's really
amazing I am glad we have it on there
yeah and we're getting me I love you I
love you thank you for that
you're my best friend you're my best
friend
knocked me a little kiss